there was one anime club at sydney uni
and i joined it
and uh i went to one of their events
yeah just
one and it was a screening and it was
off paprika right i was like okay it's a
screening
and it's of a non ghibli movie okay
whoever is picking it
must know and they have they have taste
they they know something outside of just
miyazaki i know i was like okay and and
i wanted to watch paprika because i
hadn't seen it yet
and so i went to it and the club wasn't
that big it was maybe
i'd say 40 people in this room yeah
which is quite small club for especially
sydney uni
and i was like okay these people all
seem to be excited about this movie
let's watch it
and this is the one thing i hate about
anime clubs and also this is the one
thing i hate about cinemas in the us
is that they love to [ __ ] commentate
on what's happening in the movie i
cannot stand that
i can't [ __ ] i can't stand especially
us cinemas
yes it's something about your cinemas
where it's like if there's like a big
epic right like say you go and watch
[ __ ] avengers or something
yeah and something massive happens or
some you know whatever
there's always like at least 10 or 20
people who are just like
yeah and they just go off about like
they give like they're like [ __ ]
rotten tomatoes like on your spot i feel
like i'm 80 years old whenever i'm on
like one of those screens because i'm
just like
quiet down i'm trying to enjoy the film
i'm like can you
i'm like shut the [ __ ] up we're trying
to watch the movie there's like special
occasions you know where it's kind of
warranted like watching uh
end game all right i get it you can
shout i watch pro man
ax insane the hype made it amazing you
the worst thing was
i uh one of my exes i went to the cinema
with never watched i've been
uh a movie in the cinema before and i
was like all right cool
and then she was one of those people
didn't know that because how you how do
you know that that's not like on a
tinder buyer right
and then she like shouted during the
first five minutes and i was like
okay in my head i'm thinking all right
let's let's not make this a reoccurring
thing
and then like two minutes later shouts
again and i'm like please
please don't do that please i'm i'm
british
i can't do this i can't be seen with you
if you're making a commotion in public
yeah and that's how i realized that it
wasn't right for me that's why i like
japanese synonyms man because like
it's no okay okay go ahead go ahead i
don't know i know how you feel about
japanese cinemas
all right but like for uh there's a part
of it
that i like and there's a part of it
that i don't like the part that i like
about it is that people aren't [ __ ]
shouting their rotten tomatoes reviews
no one says anything no one says
anything i like that
yeah i like that too because especially
if it's a movie that you need to immerse
yourself in like a [ __ ] paprika
for instance it's like i wanted to be
just quiet and and i want to get into it
yeah but
the uh the bad thing is that i went to
go see the connor super movie
right which is easily one of the
funniest anime movies i've ever seen
yeah and i
but i felt really bad laughing out loud
because i was literally the only person
laughing out loud in the cinema
and every time i was like [ __ ]
i don't think that was supposed to be
funny did anybody else find that funny
i've had similar experiences in uh thai
movies or
going to thai cinemas where i remember
watching your name in thai cinemas and i
don't know if it's just a cultural
difference
yeah but there would be times when they
were laughing and i would be like
what what why why is this funny and then
there'd be a really funny joke and then
i'd be the only guy laughing
i'm like am i the [ __ ] here am i do i
just have a weird really weird sense of
humor i know i i feel so bad because i
was like
is is anyone genuinely not finding this
movie funny like
am i the only one yeah i i hated it i've
been going to the cinema at least before
kovid like i was going like pretty much
every week
and like there's some other things they
do great like i know
i showed you guys this in the cinema
yeah that when you get buy popcorn on
the drink they give you this
this tray yeah and you're like oh that's
cool and then you realize
you can put it in the cup holder yeah
and it sticks so you have a whole tray
that's in the cup holder it's [ __ ]
genius yeah no i don't have to hold this
[ __ ]
yeah yeah i can just put it on you don't
have to put like [ __ ] greasy things
yeah yeah put your popcorn on your tray
and the person next you can
you know have it whatever amazing right
amazing and then uh the thing that i
hate
oh also yeah no noise the only time i've
ever seen the make noise in a japanese
cinema right i was watching the movie
and it was about a bomb that was
gonna go off in one of the olympics
right yeah and it's this police officers
accused anyway they go to his house to
search his house
and they ask him do you have any guns
he's like yeah i have guns
and he shows his like under his mattress
and he has like a hundred guns
meanwhile if they show that in the u.s
cinema you know there's like yeah
and then also one really annoying thing
right when the movie ends
right the credits come all right see you
guys i'm off
japanese cinemas you cannot leave no
until the credits are over
yeah and some of these credits go on for
like 20 [ __ ] minutes
and i'm like the first few times i was
like you know what i'll respect the
culture
now i'm just like credits i'm going [ __ ]
you guys i'm not waiting for you
caveman brain activate again
i don't i don't care about the seven
people who did costume design i'm sorry
like i'm not sticking around for that
one and then like i'm the [ __ ] who
like in front of a hundred things like
all right see you guys
i'm just walking like i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm not waiting 30 minutes yeah i i
found that aspect cool because you know
obviously the people go to the cinemas
they they they respect they're like okay
i want to know who did and who worked on
this movie
but as you said i think the japanese
like film industry is aware that people
have to stick around to the chris
they're like
how do we like extend this as long as we
can it's like a youtuber trying to
extend a video to 10 minutes right it's
like how do we extend this credit to 10
minutes to get that mid-roll in
i don't know like i've i i used to be
the same where
i would think why the [ __ ] would anyone
stay when the credits rolling i i i i
give no i
i don't give a [ __ ] about this and then
i remember i did it once for a movie
that just
blew me away um i think um i can't
remember the exact name
but i remember most recently i did it
after watching your name and silent
voice
and it's actually just a really nice
feeling just to
just to like absorb everything you just
watch and just sit there in silence i
don't know when when
are there sometimes yeah when a movie
you like hits really deep
like we're doing this again we're doing
this oh my god but when
when when a movie affects me that way
then it's just nice just to absorb
everything you just watch instead of
just being like all right boys i'm i'm
off you know i'm off that that was
movie good i'm i'm going i'm going to go
no that's that's yeah no that's the one
thing i appreciate about some uh
film credits right like you know if it's
like i really enjoy watching you know
the toy story credits because they do
the you know the behind the scenes
bloopers
reels oh no like that shit's [ __ ]
cool but when it's
a black screen it's just white text
scrolling
which it often is which it often is and
then i'm just like
i mean you guys know we have to stick
around for the craze can you at least
make it
entertaining in some fashion and even
isn't it the worst
as well when the credits song is just
like i'm not digging this credits
at all and i have to [ __ ] sit here
and listen to the whole god damn song
i'm too lazy for that i just leave and
then i i watch the after scene credit on
youtube yes it's going to be
yeah but you can use the gaijin card
right uh yeah i mean
no one really cares sometimes when i do
it the japanese were like well we can do
that
and then they'll get up too i noticed
i never thought you could do that
because when i do it i notice i'll get a
few lucks and then i'll be like two of
the people who stand up and go as well
yeah i'm like yeah join me
it is it is freedom so
it's like it's like the trust system
that japan runs on like buying alcohol
i'm slowly breaking it
i don't know i i've just the more i
don't know i say the older i get
i the more i i you know have less time
the more i just don't appreciate [ __ ]
that wastes my time
and i'm just like nope i'm not waiting
for your credits yeah